all right we're taking some of your
questions in this segment here on this
wednesday edition of pft live we put out
the call the questions have been
screened and let's begin with brian
byrne who goes by the twitter handle at
brian burnsey come on man stidham over
tua fourth round picker has thrown two
passes for a pick six you just know to
his popularity is through the roof and
you did this for click bait be better i
love it when they accuse us of click
bait where there's nothing to click
what's what's there to click it's not
clever i don't know either it's i don't
know either
no you know and hey listen
brian burnsie i i appreciate the thought
you know and again i hate that click
bait crap i do i don't give a damn about
whether you click on it or not brian
burnsey okay you know i don't i'm doing
this because this is what i love to do
and this is what i believe and this is
where my studies and you know with all
the great people i've been fortunate to
learn from and be around and all those
things that's where i've come up with
this assessment and i don't give a damn
that the nfl got it wrong and drafted
jared sidham in the fourth round that
doesn't matter he was a first round pick
that a lot of idiots in the football
fell for the old well the team wasn't
good the quarterback must have not been
good you know if you put tua on that
auburn team that jared stidham played
with that last year in auburn uh two
will probably would have been relegated
to the fourth round as well you know so
jared stidham is playing plan a for the
new england patriots they like what they
see they know he has starting
quarterback material and mike i don't
know if you know anybody in new england
if you've heard those same thoughts but
uh i am a big fan of jared sidham and i
think he's going to be the quarterback
and we'll still be talking about him for
the new england patriots five years from
now
my opinion in that regard has been
gleaned from the things that players
have said publicly by the circumstances
the circumstantial evidence is strong
bill belichick knows a thing or two
about football josh mcdaniels knows a
thing or two about offense they wouldn't
have drafted him they wouldn't have
groomed him
they wouldn't have essentially shrugged
their shoulders when tom brady was
packing up his stuff and leaving boston
if they didn't believe that they had
something in jared stidham and right
those six super bowls that the patriots
have won over the course of the past 20
years would tend to i think at least buy
a sliver of doubt for bill belichick as
we wait to see what stidhum has and with
tua there's the question of is he
damaged goods is he going to be able to
hold up at the nfl level i think that's
part of the the evaluation as well
plenty of others though have chimed in
taking issue with your decision to put
stidhum ahead of tua that's been a
common theme and and we'll see and
another thing i like about you if you're
ultimately wrong you'll say so
i know
you're not you're not gonna defend it
and say i really was right if it's
proven that you're wrong you you admit
you're wrong and that's good that's
refreshing not enough people do that
either well it's not a right or wrong
business you're not always going to be
just like oh plain as day right or wrong
you know no it's it's an evaluation it's
projections there's a lot of things that
go into it there's so many moving parts
and you know again like i just said you
know hey listen i think my credentials
are pretty good in the in this area uh
but at the same time do i think that
everything i say or do goes in you know
the holy grail and written in stone no
absolutely not you know you're gonna
mess up in this business if bill
belichick can mess up a draft pick then
damn chris sims can mess up a draft
evaluation or a quarterback ranking i i
know that it's just not a perfect
business that way
andy who goes by the twitter handle at
tape merchant would like to know the
answer to this question do you think
tyrod taylor the chargers quarterback
this year has a shot of winning comeback
player of the year chris what do you
think
yeah well you know what do you think i
think there's a real good chance i do
you know i just think with you know
again as we know with these type of
awards it's about yes you have to have
some good stats but then it has to be
the team is playing well in a high level
too to justify hey this guy was a
comeback player and it helped his team
out and do all those things and i think
the chargers have an appropriate support
system to make that happen for tyrod
taylor you know when you go from you
know what were they last year five and
11 and then all of a sudden you're back
in the playoff conversation and you're
the quarterback you have a good chance
to win that award
here's the thing about comeback player
of the year and and this applies to mvp
you know some of these other awards that
are given out every year by the ap
there really isn't a lot of definition
as to what it means what are you coming
back from yeah right right injury are
you coming back from being benched ryan
tannehill came back from not being very
good right i mean matthew stafford won
comeback player of the year i think in
2011 it's like he was never here
what's he coming back to
he never did anything he has one good
year and he's come back player of the
year so it's a very vague and amorphous
category but he would fit
within the confines of comeback player
of the year if he comes out and has a
huge season he's got to have a huge
season he's got to lead the chargers to
the postseason i mean just like ryan
tannehill did last year it's got to be a
surprise it's got to be the kind of
thing that gets our attention and says
wow tyrod taylor even though he was
never a great quarterback right he took
a team to the playoffs he's 20
26 23 and one as a starter so yeah i
think that if if he would lead the
chargers to a postseason appearance have
4 000 passing yards uh they go you know
eleven and five ten and six yeah he'd be
one of the candidates for comeback
player of the year now you don't
determine that in a vacuum because we
don't know who else out there coming
like a ben roethlisberger if the
steelers go twelve and four and win the
division he'll probably be comeback
player of the year but uh it all depends
on who else is in the mix but i think
the tyrod taylor if he plays well and
the chargers win games will be in the
mix chris
yeah i do too i do you know the defense
is good we know that i think they've
made the appropriate you know fixes to
the offense they've improved that
offensive line there is some good
receivers they got hunter henry
hopefully he can stay healthy and yeah
would you look at all those angles and
then tyrod taylor who's a guy who is not
known to take a lot of chances or be
careless with the football so he's not
going to lose games for the chargers
that way
yeah i i do i think he's one of those
guys that i would put a little mark next
to to say watch out for this guy he
could be a comeback player or the gear
candidate
all right next question comes from
brad smith i assume this is not the same
brad smith we mentioned just within the
past half hour catching the touchdown
pass from ryan fitzpatrick while playing
for the jets it would be one hell of a
coincidence if it is at brad versus all
would you rather have christian
mccaffrey at his current contract or
odell beckham jr at his current contract
chris i i already know the answer is
you're going to take otto beckham jr
i always take odell beckham jr don't i
exactly positive or something yes but
but i do think like it legitimately i
would here even as a you know i know i'm
fanboy of obj and that's my guy and yes
i root for him i like christian
mccaffrey a whole lot too but i think
two the other thing that you have to
play into this this question or the
answer is you know odell beckham jr the
current status of his contract i mean a
lot of the big money's been paid so you
know there's more wiggly someone else
well you're right by the giants
so i think just from that standpoint
alone i'd rather have obj at his
contract at this point with instead of a
running back who's just starting a big
money contract and we know how brutal
that position is and everything like
that so i think
legitimately i would take obj here even
though it's close what do you think
average salary under the mccaffrey deal
is 16 million average under the beckham
deal is 18. now look you're right the
big money's already been paid out it was
paid out by the giants um
mccaffrey well
but look
i hear here's one argument christian
mccarthy touches the ball more
frequently than other beckham jr he's a
running back he's a receiver he's an
all-around weapon right so right he has
you could argue he's got more intrinsic
value to your team that way but a great
receiver
affects the offense even if he's not
touching the football no
offense for everybody else so right
that's the that's the response to that
it doesn't matter if otto beckham jr
isn't getting 30 touches a game and what
receiver is ever going to get that but
his presence allows the running back
allows nick chubb to be nick chubb in
cleveland whereas if you didn't have
christian mccaffrey and you had otto
beckham jr maybe you could draft a guy
who comes in and you're paying him
peanuts who can have a hell on impact
because you've got double coverage all
the time on obj so
i hate to do it i'm going to i think
it's objective too i know i'd if i could
and now i got to make four more years
but i got 14 million 14 500 1375 1375
and here's the thing at some point in
the course of the next four years he's
going to want to raise you have to
factor that into it as well i think that
probably already does but i i think that
the impact of his presence
um
it outweighs
the the difference between what
mccaffrey does
and what the next man up would do for a
hell of a lot less money if that makes
any sense at all no no i think it does
it makes a whole lot of sense also you
know you could play the angle too that
you know when you get to this point of
the career with guys that are running
back in a receiver we see that you know
more times than not the receivers play
at a higher level for a longer time than
the running backs the running backs
tend to fall off you know year four five
six where all of a sudden we see a
slippage and explosion and some of the
things they can do physically but the
big thing mike is is what you're talking
about i mean it's very real it really
jumped out to me last year in cleveland
even when he wasn't a hundred percent
you know teams show him so much
attention and there's always two people
over him and he could be running a five
yard shallow cross route and there's two
guys chasing after him and it opens up
everybody else and helps the run game
and helps jarvis landry the tight ends
all of that so uh you know i'm expecting
a big year from odell as we know because
i think last year was a little
lackluster for for his standards but uh
i agree with you you know it's a big
effect on the team he'd be one of those
guys i'd love to show fans what he
really does on film and how it affects
the whole offense and the overall game
itself
well we should do that sometime we've
got we've got time we've got
opportunities right that's something we
do to to illustrate the impact of a
great receiver on the rest of an offense
because it is very real and i think
that's what tipped the scales for me all
right one more real quickly at br adams
what will the nfl do if a player test
positive for the coronavirus obviously
the day after playing in a game let me
try this one first yeah
the player gets the player gets
quarantined and it's not like you need
to do contact tracing because
everybody's going to be getting tested
all the time anyway contact tracing is
relevant
where you're otherwise not going to be
tested you're going about your life but
i think with every player being tested
every day and i think they need to be
tested on the way into the facility and
on the way out of the facility players
coaches everyone who's in that petri
dish that is the nfl locker room needs
to be tested every day arguably twice
per day you the guy's positive the day
after playing in a game he's shut down
for however long they agree players are
going to be shut down once they test
positive period and that's what the nfl
and the nfl players association need to
work out
that's that's exactly it i mean they do
i mean what what happens if that happens
and then we find out you know three days
later that you know half the team that
they just played also test positive and
you know the guy uh on team a that was
the original positive test how half his
team test positive see these are things
too that this is where the nfl and nfl
pa got to start talking this out right
now they got to get it going they got to
understand her you know will nfl players
just basically say well we don't care
that there's coronavirus in the locker
room let's just keep playing the hell
with it i think you might get more
positive answers that way than people
realize but we don't know and i just i
that that's where i keep stressing this
over the last two weeks i would hope
some of these conversations are
happening behind the scenes right now uh
because this is what i do fear that we
play three weeks of football and all of
a sudden two guys in the league get it
and we find out on a monday morning and
all of a sudden two teams are devastated
and have the kobit 19 virus and then
where do we go do we cancel the lee or
cancel a few weeks of games i don't know
and again that's why it's a deep subject
no and you're absolutely right we don't
know how this is going to play out they
don't know how it's going to play out
but the reality is
if there's a guy who makes his way into
a locker room onto a practice field or
onto a game site
and is positive and he's shedding virus
as the experts say
it's going to get around and others are
going to have it and others are going to
test positive and how how many extra
guys are you going to need on the roster
i mean here's the thing here's the thing
uh the solution may just be
shut down everyone who's positive and go
out and and sign as many players as you
need to sign they're going to need some
sort of a short-term
ir designation
where you come and go uh you're on the
coronavirus list for two weeks
and good point your roster spot is over
right and it's gonna be look if they
were willing in the 1987 strike to go
out and find replacement players for
three weeks to keep the games going they
will do it
if players are unable to play because
they're positive for the coronavirus
they'll be down and someone else steps
up and it's going to take more i think
than just 10 guys on the practice squad
you're gonna have to have other guys in
reserve ready to go at a moment's notice
to come in and play in the event like
you said half the team ends up testing
positive out of the blue
yeah that's and you know that's that's
tough yeah i don't you know those are
things i look at right now and you just
go man i mean yeah this is quite the
contingency plan that you're going to
have to worry about and yeah maybe
they're going to have to expand the the
practice squad this year and the rosters
a little bit because of that to where
yeah you got to have a little more extra
you know some extra guys to come off the
bench and help the team out because the
other thing too mike that i would be
scared of if you just like start signing
guys off the street on a wednesday or
thursday afternoon and
now they got to play in a game on sunday
one i'm worried about their health and
safety because they're not going to be
in football shape and ready to go and
then two i'm also going to be worried
about the other guys that got to play
with this guy because because he's not
going to be in football shape and the
legs and knees might be wobbly and he
might get tired he's not used to getting
knocked around from all different angles
he can end up hurting somebody else too
so that's that's a real worry and uh
again i think these are other these are
points that the the nfl and the nfl pa i
would i would i just want to hear more
dialogue or more about it and i don't
hear anything and that scares me a
little
last thing on this for now we may
discuss it at pftot look at what the xfl
did
during their short run they had a ninth
team of guys who were constantly kept in
game shape and available to be called up
at a moment's notice maybe they need to
have
teams that aren't playing but practicing
and ready to go and you just cherry-pick
guys off of those teams as needed based
upon who test pause
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports